throughout history political activists
have endured all manner of suffering in
order to advance their causes Gandhi
marched 240 miles to protest the British
salt Monopoly Nelson Mandela spent 27
years in prison opposing the South
African regime and yesterday Democrat
Congressman Greg kasar stopped eating
for eight hours to protest for more
breaks in the workday in Texas when
Congressman casear first demanded more
time offer employees I didn't know if he
was serious
but when the congressman for went his
mid-afternoon snack to bring attention
to the issue I knew he meant business
now of course there was a time when
Americans weren't such fatties that they
could go a few hours without stuffing
their faces and not hold a press
conference about it there was even a
time when people fasted regularly as a
matter of religious or even just
physical discipline but those days are
gone and in the decadent year of Our
Lord 2023 a brief Interruption of
gluttony constitutes an act of political
heroism right now go to puretalk.com
Knowles you know a company is looking
out for you when they actually upgrade
your service and don't charge you for it
this is great news for new and current
Pure Talk customers pure talk just added
data to every plan and includes a mobile
hotspot with no price increase
whatsoever if you've considered pure
talk before but haven't made the switch
take a look again for just 20 bucks a
month you will get unlimited talk text
and now 50 more 5G data plus their new
mobile hotspot this is why I love Pure
Talk veteran owned they only hire the
best customer service team located right
here in the great us of a that alone is
worth switching most families are saving
almost a thousand dollars a year while
enjoying the most Dependable 5G Network
in America remember
you vote with how you spend your money
so stop supporting wireless companies
that don't support you go to
puretalk.com Knowles you'll save an
additional 50 off your first month
because they value you go to
puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk Wireless
for Americans buy Americans that is
puretalk.com
slash Knowles hi Michael I'm a fellow
Catholic and new tier show and heard you
mention how you and your wife came back
together after some time apart I was
wondering how realistic that would be in
my situation I met the most amazing man
and we were in a great relationship
until he made a big life change which
made him very stressed and overwhelmed
he told me he couldn't be in a
relationship but that he wanted to see
me again in the future
it's been almost a year we don't talk
but we're on good terms and I still hold
on to the hope that we can get back
together I'm 37 he's 47 we had a solid
connection and we're honest with each
other I keep hoping that he will come
back but I don't know what else I can do
at this point any advice thank you
yes I'm sorry to hear about your
situation I would dump that zero and get
yourself a hero that's what I would do
he sounds like a schmuck
I know you like him still and I don't
know why he instigated this breakup and
he needed time to find himself or
whatever nonsense but he sounds like a
big putz and you should dump him sorry
to say I know I'm sure you like him and
maybe you guys spent a lot of time
together but
there there are ways to get back
together with someone that you've broken
up with obviously I'm living proof of
that but the the thing that got me about
what you said is you don't talk
and I don't think there's really a way
to get back together or it's much less
likely that you will get back together
if you're not still talking so you're on
good terms it was a perfectly fine
breakup but you're not still talking
you're not in each other's lives and
you're holding out this hope for this
guy and what is he saying he had a big
life change I don't know what the life
change is it really could be anything it
could be maybe what did he get a new job
did he did a family member die did he
have to move somewhere or whatever it is
if a man
especially a man of his age cannot
handle whatever that change is there
going to be a lot of changes in life
life comes at you fast and also maintain
a loving relationship that one hopes
moves towards marriage then he's just
not the right guy he might be the
sweetest guy in the world he just
doesn't have his act together okay you
should have a guy who does have his act
together so
so I'm sorry to give harsh advice here
because maybe there's a one percent
chance that you guys could get back
together I wouldn't I wouldn't hang my
hopes on that dump him you can do better
my dear good morning Michael first off
I've been listening to your show for
quite some time and I really appreciate
that you not only addressed the major
issues facing out of society
but also address the spiritual warfare
behind all of it
it's my question I'm curious about your
take on different Christian
denominations
my family and I attend a church that
would fall into the non-denominational
category
we believe in the Bible and that
repentance and a relationship with Jesus
is the only way to Salvation and eternal
life
I know that you belong to the Catholic
church and that you often refer to
Catholic traditions on your show
do you believe that Catholicism is the
only way to Salvation or is it more of a
difference of style and tradition if so
you believe that all sects of
Christianity lead to Salvation are there
ones that get it completely wrong
again thank you for your continued work
to Bringing truth to the world
really good question
I'm Catholic and so I believe that the
Catholic Church possesses the fullness
of truth I think it's the real church
that Christ instituted and one of the
evidences of this I take it on faith but
one of the evidences of this according
to the great writer Hillary bellock is
that if the church were not divinely
instituted no other navish no other
institution conducted with such Navy
imbecility would have lasted a fortnight
so the problems and the scandals and the
corruption in a way are a kind of an
Evidence is nothing but divine grace
could possibly have allowed an
institution so mismanaged to to continue
um you say you were non-denominational
and I have many friends who call
themselves that
so many so that I would have to suggest
that the n and the D are capitalized you
know the non-denominational denomination
because it is a denomination because
people refer to it by that name I've got
family who were Baptists you know I've
got a lot of Protestants down the family
tree
um
so are all people who say that they're
Christian
saved are they Christian
uh
well the Bible seems clear enough on
this which is Christ says someday there
will be people who call me Lord Lord who
I will say I will to whom I will say I
do not know you uh so
I'm not saying that you know you and
your fellow ecclesial Community you know
you're all going to rot in hell I'm not
saying anything like that and I'm not
saying that you don't have a sincere
faith in Christ and I'm not saying that
that you know Christ has not bestowed
his grace upon you or anything like that
but at the very least we would have to
say that if you came out and you said
God forbid you know I believe in Jesus
well what does that mean to you well it
means you know that I believe in
and I believe in abortion I think
abortion is a really important thing
it's a Sacrament and I believe in
chopping off people's body parts and I
believe in Acts murdering people twice a
month that's my understanding of
Christianity what would you say that's
crazy that's not Christianity what on
Earth are you talking about that's so
but but no I'm calling myself a
Christian well no and there are certain
Christian
so-called Christian denominations which
deny important aspects of the faith
would you call them Christian well no
it'd be hard to do that
the question that I would ask myself if
I were
shopping around for different
denominations and sex and things like
that is okay I love Christ I love the
Lord I love God I want to do his will
is there a way that he wants me to
worship Him is there a way that he wants
me to have a relationship with him is
there specificity is there detail to it
does he give clues of this in the Bible
of ways that he wants us to pray what
things that he wants us to believe
Creeds that he wants us to hold does he
give us
clues in the early Christian tradition
in the early Church in the later church
is there some continuity there the first
part very important part is do you love
the Lord do you accept Christ as the
Lord your God will you be baptized and
then even as you as you're baptized okay
is there something else is it not so
much how I want to worship God but how
God wants me to worship him for my own
good
uh you see that certainly in the Old
Testament very very rigid descriptions
by God of how he wants his chosen people
to worship him and I think that remains
true today and so this process of
discernment of of what the truth of the
matter is it's not you know being
nitpicky and finicky and exclusive or
anything like that it's just asking okay
I'm with you Lord I love you
what do you want from me boy what a
great clip that was make sure that you
ring the bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel see you next
time